ah j'ai trouvé un objet dites-vous que
par exemple dans la boîte de l'un de
l'autre il y a peut-être votre numéro de
téléphone qui va [ __ ] [ __ ] on est
trop près on se terrifiant ce qui se
passe il faut appuyer peut-être faire
autre chose avec si c'est une
constellation là je n'arriverai jamais
attends je suis tellement nul ça
c'est pas ça là
salut aujourd'hui on va pas faire un
casse-tête dans le sens où je ne vais
pas résoudre une énigme ou un casse-tête
d'ailleurs c'est même pas un casse-tête
c'est deux casse-tête et c'est mieux que
ça c'est un battle de casse-tête que je
vous explique la situation aujourd'hui
sur Netflix sort un nouveau film qui
s'appelle glassone une histoire à
couteau tirer dans cette histoire il y a
des gens qui sont invités en Grèce chez
quelqu'un de très riche et qui n'envoie
pas des invitations comme les autres il
envoie des sortes de boîtes à énigme il
faut résoudre l'énigme pour avoir
l'invitation ensuite les gens partent
là-bas en Grèce je vous spoiles pas le
film mais en gros c'est toute une
histoire d'enquête sur des meurtres il y
a une ambiance un peu Cluedo mélangée à
du Sherlock et du Hercule Poirot nous on
va se concentrer sur le départ sur quand
il reçoivent ces boîtes incroyables
celle-ci elles ont été créées pour
l'occasion vraiment dans l'univers du
film et j'ai invité Sofiane et Seb ils
vont faire tous les deux les boîtes les
casse-têtes en même temps
[Musique]
venez près de moi vous avez à côté de
vous deux grosses boîtes et en fait dans
le film de glaçons la personne qui
invite tout le monde sur son île en
Grèce envoie des boîtes avec les
invitations à l'intérieur mais c'est
vraiment des boîtes casse-tête aussi des
choses qu'il faut qu'il faut résoudre
vous vous avez des versions inspirées
sauf qu'à l'intérieur vous avez pas des
invitations dans ta boîte à toi Sofiane
il y a un secret qui concerne Seb et
dans ta boîte à toi il y a un secret qui
concerne Sofiane donc vous allez voir un
petit truc de rapidité moi je suis avec
vous pour vous donner des indices aussi
peut-être pour vous donner des bonus des
malus je vais vous poser des questions
je vais vous perturber des fois vous
allez vous perturber vous êtes libre
mais gardez en tête un truc vous devez
être les premiers à finir la boîte on
est arrivé aujourd'hui
les secrets qui vous concernent ça peut
être n'importe quoi dites-vous que par
exemple dans la boîte de l'un de l'autre
il y a peut-être votre numéro de
téléphone qui va [ __ ] ok cool voilà
cool résoudre
sortir en premier qui va avec le numéro
on va pas vous faire commencer en même
temps je trouve ce serait trop facile de
toute façon après tu copies l'autre tu
fais ok il a trouvé comment
je vais que dire l'inverse de ce que je
fais ça tu pourras jamais prendre les
amis si tu dis ça du coup il a juste
inversé tout ce que tu dis oui mais
c'est comme si je dis pierre-feu ciseau
vas-y fais ciseau bah c'est exactement
cette tête je vais le faire c'est
exactement ce qu'on va faire pour
commencer on va faire un chifoumi OK et
le premier qui marque un point sur
l'autre il aura un bonus de 30 secondes
c'est-à-dire il va pouvoir commencer 30
secondes avant d'être visible
[Musique]
à 30 secondes d'avance pendant ces 30
secondes tu peux faire ce que tu veux tu
peux changer tu peux observer tu peux
faire ce que tu veux il faut commencer
30 secondes
c'est parti maintenant regarde
OK
ah il a pas vu le truc derrière parce
qu'il voit pas de son côté le truc le
truc avec l'autre côté je dois
comprendre
comme ça donc elle souffre comme ça
là
attends je suis débile de cou je suis
désolé d'accord il reste plus que 10
secondes avant que toi tu commences
vas-y je peux y aller moi là Sofiane
rentre dans la partie ça s'appuie ok
c'est bon j'ai trouvé un objet
c'est de le vrai
c'est un bon point de départ c'est un
petit loupe il faut toujours prendre le
temps d'explorer c'est sûr c'est c'est
bien usiné ça va c'est bien
analyse un peu je suppose que ça on est
d'accord on touche pas enfin c'est
exactement on touche pas au câble et
tous les éléments de déco n'ont rien à
voir avec ce que vous avez à faire
aujourd'hui ça se passe de ton côté ça
écoute est-ce que tu trouves que c'est
30 secondes donc vachement servi pas
trop pas tellement pas trop c'est pas un
si grand avantage en tout cas pas à ce
stade de l'enquête bon ici on a des
serrures là il y a un truc aimanté
de première classe
il y en a un des deux qui a de l'avance
sur l'autre et les deux ne font pas les
mêmes choses actuellement arrête je suis
trop con mais je suis trop con
attends
c'est pas mal du tout
la boîte à parler peut-être même qu'elle
te montre quelque chose
mais elle est merveilleuse cette boîte
non mais attends c'est fou tu as vu le
bruit
[Musique]
tu sais que depuis quelques minutes vous
avez plus exactement la même boîte
pourquoi la tienne elle ressemble pas
tout à fait à la sienne je n'ai jamais
vu ça j'ai le droit d'aller voir non
comment je peux savoir comment je peux
savoir si attends mais je me dis un truc
là qu'est-ce qui se passe ah je suis
trop stressé alors c'est pas un concours
de vitesse en fait
il y a une notion de vitesse mais
faudrait que tu répondes à une question
la question c'est connais-tu la date de
naissance de Sofiane
je veux dire comme c'est un ami
[Rires]
[Musique]
il est né ça c'est vrai
franchement je crois que tu es né le
matin ou le soir
c'est pas vrai
de dire la date de naissance de Seb
pardon je sais faire très bon et là ça
m'énerve là ça y est ça commence donc le
Nord
c'est en février non début février oui
c'est début février c'est le [ __ ] je
sais pas je dirais 7 un truc comme ça
c'est en septembre ah non c'est le 3
septembre
[Musique]
mais c'est mars
bon ok quand le premier des deux qui est
capable de dire mon âge précis je lui
donne un indice 33 tu as 37 non
4 31 35 ah ouais mais tu vois que tu as
plus
[Musique]
le mois dernier l'indice que je vais te
donner c'est il va être oral ok ok non
mais les gars
du coup est-ce que tu savais que c'est
dans la vie il y a toujours un ordre
pour faire les choses
il doit y avoir une séquence donc là si
je fais là après là
et ça revient au début ok donc on va
faire tac tac
[Musique]
le premier qui est capable de me dire
il s'est passé là
tu as été très rapide pour l'ouvrir très
satisfaisant incroyable bon tu sais quoi
on vient on va aider cette banque
là on a un trou ici il y a trois
encoches de billes donc il faut les
amener maintenant il faut trouver
comment les amener là-bas oh on peut le
prendre
on va essayer de l'emmener de l'emmener
là-bas soit tout à l'heure tu as eu un
bonus tu as commencé 30 secondes avant
lui là tu auras un malus tu as le droit
de regarder mais pas de toucher pendant
30 secondes ok alors que toi ça va
commencer à partir de maintenant let's
go
en fait je fais tellement peu ce genre
de truc que j'ai pas les mécanismes j'ai
pas pensé
de Sofiane je pense qu'il aura fini
l'intégralité de la boîte d'ici 30
secondes
[Rires]
2 1 résoudre moi cette phase là il a il
a gagné la première manche tu dois
gagner la deuxième c'est sûr parce que
cette histoire
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc c'est
marrant parce que en fait sa
problématique actuelle c'est
oh là là
ok un tiroir c'est tout vert avec deux
dents
une lampe et ça c'est parfait ça c'est
la bille qui manque pour la mettre ici
et pour l'emmener jusque là-bas donc
déjà on va commencer par la lettre mais
même moi ça m'a fait peur c'est normal
je te laisse continuer non mais je suis
désolé comment on commence à marche
je peux avoir un indice bien sûr si vous
êtes capable de répondre à la question
suivante oui dans quel film Netflix a
joué Sofiane
très belle question si j'étais un super
héros un truc comme ça non [ __ ] c'est
un truc c'est une question et si j'avais
des super pouvoirs
il dit tous les mots du champ lexical
comment je suis devenu un super héros
est-ce que c'est validé comment comment
c'est validé le titre précis s'il vous
plaît Sofiane c'est comment je suis
devenu super héros
vous m'avez demandé un indice par
rapport à ça j'ai envie de vous dire
l'indice que je vais vous donner c'est
que votre problème actuel c'est
exactement le même problème que vous
avez vu avec la loupe que j'ai pas vu
c'est un problème de quoi que vous aviez
avec la loupe de magnétisme
stylé bien sûr ok mais ça m'énerve en
fait de de passer à côté de trucs aussi
bête
pour moi pour moi ça c'est pas c'est pas
utile parce que tu as décidé à la place
des créativité
commis je peux retrouver les traces ok
ah bah oui bah ça c'est très clair là on
a l'intérieur du labyrinthe qui est
caché par la plaque de bois donc ça va
me permettre de faire mon tracé pour
emmener celle-ci là-bas parce que t'as
pas l'impression de devenir un
super-héros regarde c'est exceptionnel
c'est comme ça que tu es devenu
super-héros dans cette deuxième étape on
a toujours une avance quand même du côté
de Sofiane bien sûr
on passe là
OK
[Musique]
ok j'ai fini le bonhomme là ah non
ok ça c'est fait
ok je te le retire on ne touche à rien
c'est à quoi des couches ah c'est pour
ça on est en train de peler l'oignon ça
va être le titre de la vidéo
[Musique]
que moi pense à tous les objets que tu
as c'est fou mais moi aussi
[Rires]
c'est très très fort c'est fort et
[ __ ] qu'est-ce qu'on est bête
pour l'instant messieurs c'est assez
incroyable ça c'est tous les indices qui
étaient prévus il y a des jeux qui
étaient prévus pour vous donner des
indices pour vous débloquer je pensais
pas que vous iriez aussi rapidement ok
cette troisième étape elle est composée
de plusieurs points comme ça de contrôle
qu'il va falloir faire toi tu as donc le
droit de me demander un indice à tout
moment ok une fois pour avoir terminé
comme ça en premier mais n'oublie pas la
malédiction de Mario Kart on est premier
tout long
donc si toi tu arrives en deuxième ton
secret sera révélé du côté de chez SEB
ok moi j'ai une question ouais on est à
la même étape vous êtes à la même étape
mais là à partir de maintenant il y a
plus de Checkpoint il y a plus d'étapes
c'est à dire que là à partir de
maintenant ça s'arrêtera plus
là
c'est bon pour vous 4 3 2 1 Go
ok on est sur une structure où il y a
quatre cases sur les quatre cases il y
en a une qui s'est ouverte ça a l'air
d'être un taquin on connaît les taquins
on sait très joli en plus on a tous les
éléments qui forment le logo de
glasonium j'imagine assez facilement
qu'il faut le remettre dans l'ordre ce
qui est pas si simple parce que c'est
des motifs qui va falloir comprendre de
comment on les remet la partie centrale
c'est très clair c'est que la Sonia mais
pour le reste c'est pas si évident
[ __ ] je déteste ça c'est vrai parce
qu'il y a une logique que je que je sais
qu'elle existe mais je la connais pas
parce que c'est soit tu parles pas du
tout comme Sofiane soit à chaque fois
que tu fais un truc tu fais ok comme
c'est vrai ok ok c'est ok ça je le
laisse ok c'est bon
donc si vous voulez voir le film allez
sur Netflix et chercher glace
là c'est vraiment l'endroit où tu peux
gagner du temps sur l'autre ou en perdre
[Musique]
le taquin ça a libéré la deuxième partie
donc j'imagine qu'ils vont s'ouvrir tous
les Castres dans l'ordre et on a deux
ours c'est d'ailleurs des espèces de
petits trucs qui font de la lumière et
un câble que j'ai peur de toucher parce
que j'ai peur de prendre le jus en fait
ce que j'ai l'impression qu'il allume
lui parce qu'il le touche ah ouais c'est
vraiment un fil très fin OK et dès que
le fil il touche quelque chose ça
l'allume je pense qu'on peut d'ailleurs
peut-être même l'enrouler autour des
trucs pour les tenir d'accord donc il
faut il faut probablement faire une
séquence pour que ça puisse s'allumer et
faire quelque chose c'est au centre je
te donne un indice non ben non parce que
là
on a des petites étoiles
et si je faisais la Grande Ourse bon on
a quand même un bon indice on a un grand
ours et un petit ours et je pense même
que c'est une grande Ourse et une petite
ourse alors est-ce qu'il faut faire la
Grande Ourse ou la Petite Ourse à faire
la Grande Ourse c'est la plus connue la
Grande Ourse que je le prends comme ça
c'est bon non pourquoi c'est pas bon moi
me dis pas que c'est
que
lui il va là oh là là là là là oh c'est
terrifiant ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce que tu essayes de faire
mais du coup il y a plein de
possibilités de la faire comme je galère
c'est un truc de fou tu sais le bonus
que tu demandais ça peut être moi qui en
fait une partie vas-y je prends bonus là
ok je peux pas je suis en train de
retard sur un truc nul toi tu as
l'habitude d'en faire de ça
pas tellement mais c'est une logique qui
me parle c'est ce genre de truc alors
qu'il y a des trucs bien plus difficiles
qui vont arriver je le sais mais bon
c'est les trucs sur le sur lesquels tu
seras bon ah mince je suis bête je l'ai
vraiment
j'ai entendu un bruit mon gars il y a du
bruit du coté
c'est bon c'est bon pour moi ça va ça va
ça va ok
toi tu as un d'avance
il y en a un d'avance il est au prochain
[Musique]
ok allez
il y a pas une notion de savoir une
constellation quoi là parce que mon gars
j'y connais rien mon c'est une
constellation là je n'arriverai jamais
une constellation mais quoi
qu'est-ce que tu racontes c'est dur je
les connais je la connais pas je la vois
pas je n'arrive pas à imaginer en fait
les étoiles
[Musique]
attention le premier qui est capable de
me faire l'alphabet à l'envers le plus
longtemps possible gagne l'indice
attends je suis tellement nul ça Z
c'était trop long
je te donne juste un seul indice
c'est ça ok t'as pas le droit de le
retourner faut que tu sois faire plaisir
non mais je sais que je sais ce que
c'est la réponse je sais que c'est la
constellation mais je la connais pas du
coup je suis en train de tout tester en
train de la recréer dans ma tête là moi
ce que je peux te proposer à minima
c'est une petite carte du ciel attention
le ciel on peut le regarder de n'importe
quoi mais c'est exactement ce qu'il me
fallait parce que du coup
oh c'est bon
[Musique]
il se passe un truc là oh stylé par
contre là tu es allé super vite tu
récupères ton retard mon pote hein
je savais que c'était ça mais je l'avais
pas en tête c'était trop dur bon alors
là mon gars alors là mon gars le dernier
la loupe
c'est sûr pour aller là
je découvre en fait
c'est ça
je comprends maintenant bon je me régale
c'est cool franchement c'est mieux que
fortnite par contre tu te régaleras
moins si libertant secret quoi ça c'est
encore une autre histoire j'y pense pas
pour l'instant mais alors attends ok
mais quel rapport avec ça
quel est le lien bah après nous on est
parti du principe que vous connaissiez
l'alphabet morse par contre moi je le
connais en plus Zed
[Rires]
c'est dur en miroir genre c'est quoi la
centrale de lettres ressentent
XZ c'est stylé j'ai envie de donner un
indice pour le principe tu vois non non
moi aussi
je perds un temps fou c'est vrai
mais attention
arrête de dire toutes les mobiles
de tout à l'heure arrête
citron sur les mains
[Musique]
arrête d'appuyer en même temps c'est fou
je pense que c'est le moment le plus
agréable de la vidéo mais c'est
exactement ce que je sais exactement
c'est impossible j'ai compris Sofiane il
l'a ce petit bout de papier
je vais lui transférer
regarde je te l'enlève exactement dans 3
2 1 maintenant mais quoi tu avais un
bout de papier tu le dis tu le disais
pas
franchement j'ai tout écrit moi ben je
vais pas te mentir
aucun rapport avec le haut les X quoi on
a un Z ici est-ce que est-ce qu'il faut
faire le Z en morse comment on fait le Z
en morse ça si si ça traduit du morse
c'est soit un haut soit un S o c'est
trois longs et le S c'est trois cours
donc c'est peut-être un os ou un S le E
c'est juste un c'est un point le E donc
c'est peut-être Z e si ça c'est court ça
c'est long donc ça ferait trois longs
Zeo 0
ou 0 et ça ça fait point enfin court
long court est-ce que ça c'est un r Je
me souviens plus c'était quoi mon moyen
de mnémotechnique pour certes je regarde
mes propres vidéos les gars à quoi ça
servait le morse à la base
amorcé
[Musique]
pas fini
je sais plus comment je m'appelle et
tout moi j'arrive pas à faire le lien
qui a gagné là ça se trouve c'est ça ça
se trouve c'est un rapport avec la
j'avais pas vu
non mais
tu m'as donné
[Rires]
j'avais pas vu ça y est j'ai capté
si tu es capable de me dire comme c'est
toi qui avait quand même eu les deux
coups d'avance tout à l'heure c'était
capable de me dire 3 sons d'albums de
Seb et apprendre la vitesse tu valides
mauvais cœur ok tu vas aller tout Seb je
lis tout la durée des titres oh non
sérieux
Seb tu as le même indice que Sofiane si
tu es capable de me dire la série
préférée de Sofiane sur Netflix je crois
qu'elle livre qui me donne c'est une
bonne réponse vous pouvez donc aussi si
vous le souhaitez retourner mais non
attends attends
va falloir quand même il faut prendre un
petit quelque chose [ __ ] j'ai compris
c'est que ça c'est que ça attends une
logique
c'est sûr en fait dans cette boîte
non
c'est sûr mais je suis un gros débile
donc c'est ça il est où c'est pas
consommer beaucoup d'indices vous avez
été forte
de la fin les longs
oui bravo stylé parce que franchement je
t'ai laissé une minute ou tu étais là
non mais là il y a une logique je l'ai
pas et pile-poil après en fait je viens
de refaire un truc que j'avais déjà
tenté et que j'avais mal fait en fait ah
ouais alors ça c'est relou donc là là on
a une petite pierre que je n'arrive pas
à enlever il y a des rouleaux que je ne
peux pas bouger avec le doigt
l'interrupteur qui ne fonctionne ah si
il fonctionne comme ça et après quoi OK
et ça fait un truc là maintenant
[Musique]
j'ai cassé le glaçanienne ah c'est
peut-être pour pour valider mon truc
quoi ok donc il faut que je trouve un
chiffre à mettre là-dedans en fait on va
mettre 22 d'accord que c'est le genre de
ma naissance et apparemment glason n'a
pas été conçu en fonction du joueur de
ma naissance et de ce vent mais ça se
tait donc c'est de 0 à 99
donc là tu as converti tu te dis les
croix c'est les longs et les cours mais
je savais mais j'ai pas fait lui en fait
j'ai oublié de lui
ok attention il t'a attrapé il y a un
indice qui existe pour ce passage là
c'est indice je le donnerai contre un
mot clé et ces mots clés je vais vous le
donne pas je vous le dis rien d'autre si
j'ai le bon mot clé peut-être je serai
généreux en indice pierre bravo
mais là tu vois pareil il y a un caillou
il est là pour la déco je l'ai tenté
c'est pas un cadenas à trois trucs c'est
que c'est fait pour être résolu
facilement un cadenas à trois trucs ça
te fait x 3 mais pourquoi pas ok ok quoi
je sais que ça sert à rien mais je suis
sûr moi ça me fait concentrer plus
ok je vais te laisser trop la logique
mais je suis chez moi tout seul je pense
j'aurais fait ça en mode je vais trouver
eh mais moi je t'empêche pas de le faire
les gars c'est quoi le rapport entre un
nombre à deux chiffres et un cailloux
d'après vous caillou
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est les syllabes je donnerais pas de
réponse c'est juste pour
le le poids ce caillou en gramme bon
allez là en fait il me manque un truc
que j'ai pas
moi ça me parle un truc de un truc comme
le tableau périodique tu vois mais avec
des numéros de tableaux périodique des
éléments ah c'est le mot clé ça
peut-être le tableau des éléments
périodiques ça ce serait le 42 je te
tenter 42 en haut
je mets 42 parce que de mémoire 42 c'est
l'argent est-ce que je pense à 42 parce
que c'est l'argent ou est-ce que je
pense à 42 parce que 42 c'est la réponse
à toutes les choses de l'univers et que
je me fais brain pas un élément de pop
culture non c'est peut-être 47 l'argent
ah je sais plus là vous m'emmenez
mais je l'avais appris par cœur à
l'époque ce que j'aime bien prendre des
choses par coeur qui ne servent à rien
de 47 du coup
non pas du caillou mais zinc ou il y a
quoi comme on a quoi maintenant c'est ça
va falloir le mériter ça a l'air léger
Sofiane s'il te plaît l'artiste préféré
de Seb
[Musique]
je te le donne c'est quoi du coup la
réponse de Michael Jackson
[Musique]
secret non
complètement gagné
c'était l'aluminium ou pas c'était la
lumière je suis débile moi
c'est impossible et c'est obligé
maintenant il va falloir qu'il lise ton
secret tous les moments où il avait de
l'avance et qu'on disait attention à
l'effet Mario Kart tout était premier
tout le long c'est l'effet de la fin la
juste des fois on bloque sur des trucs
tellement bête des petits détails
[Musique]
bon il est temps de déjà de dire bravo
franchement bravo en vrai ça se joue
en fait tu dis à lumineux
plus de d'être en collab que en versus
je retourne sur Sofiane parce que pour
moi c'est pas ça parce que quand je l'ai
résolue moi j'avais fait argent et en
fait les deux ouvrent et aluminium
apparemment fonctionne donc quand tu
disais 13 je veux dire jusqu'au bout des
fausses infos et tout j'ai pas capté du
tout ok on va découvrir le secret de
Sofiane de sortir le papier ne lire ce
qu'il y a dessus je l'ai rangé très
secrètement ici même tu étais au courant
bravo tu l'as fait ton esprit est
infaillible merci
j'ai cru que c'était mon secret c'est
assis
en guise de récompense tu as entre les
mains le secret inavouable de ton ami
Sofiane il y a des moments OK
je ne crois pas un instant au mentalisme
[Musique]
avec moi et du coup le mentaliste du
coup souvent quand on y croit pas c'est
quand on met une croyance derrière en
mode c'est de la voyance ou un truc
comme ça alors que moi c'est très
rationnel tu as un spectacle je
t'explique exactement et tu fais en même
temps que moi c'est ça le truc
bah viens demain spectacle tu vois
c'était juste pour ça
ton secret sera protégé au moins pendant
un an ouais
dis-le et bip que ça c'est pas mal juste
avant de le dire je voulais juste
remercier Netflix de nous avoir fourni
ces boîtes en rapport avec le film glace
une histoire à couteau tirée qui est
sorti aujourd'hui sur Netflix allez voir
ça merci à eux parce que les boîtes pour
l'expérience en vrai c'était incroyable
et merci à vous deux aussi de les avoir
fait on vous met les liens vers glacéone
et vers tout le monde dans la
description évidemment et abonnez-vous à
cette chaîne si vous avez envie de
regarder d'autres casse-tête ou de
contenu et maintenant on termine
vraiment ce sera la fin de la vidéo sur
le secret de Seb peut-être pas bipé
peut-être biper
[Musique]
honteuse c'est rigolo ouais attention là
ça BIPE plus gros mais waouh j'aurais
aimé savoir
en fait je l'ai su jeunes ou je le
voyais de loin donc j'avais pas encore
le l'aspect ça me fait rire ok mais en
grandissant le truc ça prend un peu de
la bouteille tu fais [ __ ] mais quand
même quoi oui merci beaucoup les gars
merci à toi
à vous d'avoir regardé à très bientôt
Ciao